[Music]
so today's question comes from amy in
south dakota
my husband drank the dave ramsey
kool-aid about 10 years ago we worked
extremely hard budgeting and paying off
debt however every time we get close to
paying off his credit card something
comes up that he has to buy most
recently he bought a very expensive
rifle for hunting this purchase bothered
me but it did
but he knew
he would hold it against me if i didn't
let him get the gun
man
it was more not that this is never
happened in either of our houses are you
about ready for this though it's more
than we'd spend on a family trip
and he'll use it one week in a year for
deer hunting with his friends how do i
let this go and get back on track so
there's a lot there's a lot of layers to
that one for me i was like ah
not that that's probably happened in
your house or my house for sure
um here's the thing this call
first your husband didn't drink the
ramsay kool-aid he died he read it and
thought it was a good idea and thought
it sounded fun um and was ish right kind
of leaned into it a little bit
at the end here she writes it was more
than we would ever spend on a family
trip
he'll use it one weekend a year so she's
trying to
turn this into a math problem that he
should have known how expensive it was
relative to our vacations relative to it
this is not a math problem
this is a woman who feels betrayed
because her husband's acting like a
child and they agreed
together on a vision and he refuses to
do it to do it and so this is a betrayal
so
amy how can you let this go and help us
get back on track in my house this would
not be something we'd just let go of
this would be something that we sat down
and said not i can't believe you bought
that rifle
it would be i can't believe you betrayed
our vision that we agreed together where
we were headed and that's a totally
different conversation right absolutely
yep and it's and it's hurtful i mean and
amy you lose trust in it uh there's
frustration there all of it and i just
want to know on his side
um
you know ask him questions of like you
know did you did you consider
what was happening like what like do you
need me like get to know understand
deeper
helm and his motivations and why he's
thinking the way he is she has a line
here
i knew he would hold it against me if i
didn't let him get this
listen
i'm talking to husbands here but i'm
talking to everybody
if you and your spouse agree on a thing
and one of you has the courage when
you're having a bad day right we all do
we all buy that thing you're like i fell
off the wagon
if one of your if your spouse has the
courage to call you out on it
never
be one of those morons who holds it
against them
you let me get my gun
shut up you're on the same page that's
you know who does that children
elementary school ones in fact not even
middle school kids don't even act like
this
don't be like that if somebody has the
courage to say hey we that's a 4 500 gun
that's not a part of our vision our
vision was to be debt free to change our
family legacy to pay off our house don't
do that
say thank you for holding me accountable
and i know that hurts and it stinks and
i really really really want that
and now it's not the time so how do
people work towards that john because
that's just to me that's maturity yep
that's a level of maturity of growing up
and being a grown up
so it's someone that says okay that
sounds great but my need your correction
is to go there i need your correction is
to be like kind of spite how do you
start to work
through that
i wish it was more complicated and it's
actually pretty simple
and the magic word is practice
the magic words practice we've
fallen into this trap that we believe
every interaction
is all or nothing and it's just not and
so decide i'm going to change my
identity i'm not going to be a husband
who says this is my money i could bow
down i'm not going to be like that i'm
going to be a husband that serves my
wife make sure that our home is taken
care of and that we're all in
partnership on this we're co-creating
this vision and we're living it out
and when you feel yourself getting angry
when you feel yourself
ready to snap and even if you do you
stop and you say i'm sorry about that
you circle back and say i acted like a
fourth grader back there
i'm working hard and i'm sorry um here's
what i meant to say here's what i should
have said and we're going to keep
practicing and if you will practice over
time your body quits reacting like that
yeah because it knows it doesn't help
anything yeah right it's good and some
humility too
oh sorry amy this gets me riled up man
sorry amy it gets me riled up